je garderai nord à cambrai
[Applaudissements]
morial ont surpris les pingouins de
pittsburgh en remportant le premier
match de la série 3 de 5 samedi soir et
les deux équipes s'affrontent de nouveau
ce soir c'est une des six partis qui
sont présentés aujourd'hui dans la ligue
nationale
alors si le retour du rock et mais aussi
du baseball du basket ball c'est une
bonne nouvelle vous savez pour les bars
sportifs qui n'avait plus rien à
présenter à leurs clients depuis la mi
mars et d'ailleurs on va parler avec
jean bédard qui est président et chef de
la direction du groupe sportscene
bonjour monsieur bédard manchon on vous
retrouve dans la voiture mais leurs
assurés nous vous n'êtes pas en train de
conduire l'a annoncé lui même en toute
sécurité
ça prenait question est ce que vous avez
ressenti un peu de regards un peu de
vitamines dans l'est dans les cages aux
sports avec ce premier match jusqu'à la
dire oui peu partout il avait un très
grand engouement peut-être sur l'île de
montréal
ça s'explique probablement à l'extérieur
de la ville des poussots c'était
peut-être un peu plus tranquille mais je
pense qu'avec le match qu'on a eue
samedi la qualité du spectacle
cette semaine est vraiment une grosse
différence entre la région de montréal
les restaurants de la région montréal
puis la banlieue les régions oui puisque
c'est pour un match sec en général pas
facile pour nous en termes de sondages
région sur l'île la couronne de montréal
que se sourient les gens pensent voyage
beaucoup un excellent aujourd'hui qui on
le sait vraiment l'achalandage des
établissements oui absolument pas aussi
que c'est tout de même que vous
touristique également qui souffrent à
montréal alors qu'à l'extérieur de
montréal ça va beaucoup mieux
l'impact aussi sera différent pour les
restaurants si le canadien voit loin
dans les séries il ya actuellement des
très très excité avant le début des
séries cette fois ci c'est un petit peu
différent
évidemment on peut pas
sexiste et autant que d'habitude
festoyer autant que d'habitude
évidemment aussi mal et j'étais un peu
sceptique sur la foule je pense le
premier match a vraiment montré que ça
pouvait être un beau spectacle puis que
maintenant je pense que les canadiens
sont l'eau pour tenter de gagner non
pour tenter de gagner la loterie alexis
la prégnance une bonne nouvelle son sein
qui veulent jouer pour gagner et on
s'appelle continue comme ça on est quand
même tombé parce que les gens ont besoin
de parler d'autre chose que de cette
crise le conte depuis quatre mois la
cavité est ce que vous trouvez pas ce
que vous venez tout juste là par les
scouts ou est ce que vous trouvez que
les lignes ont réussi en général à faire
oublier le manque d'ambiance dans les
amphithéâtres
j'ai vu le match par la ligue nationale
très bien fait seul nbi bien laver ce
bal je pense qu'ils ont manqué là où
l'on en voulant faire ça dans la rue
dans différents stades avec aucun
spectateur pour le voci qui ont des
problèmes aussi sanitaire
oui je dirais que ion et ont très bien
fait ce qu'ils ont oublié 29 ans avec
l'intensité que sur la glace les joueurs
on l'a vraiment vouloir pour la coupe
oui le spectre dont je pense qu'on va
s'habituer à sa bombe
de toute façon au cours des prochaines
semaines des prochains mois maintenant
monsieur monsieur mais dans quel impact
en général pour les restaurants sportif
avec le retour des ligues fait il
n'avait pas puis à 4 mo donc c'est
évidemment le retour qui met le basket
ou 6 à longueuil qui a commencé un effet
probablement septembre ça va donner
l'occasion aux gens de télévision pour
une raison différente j'étais ce midi
dans les restaurants justement puis
d'avoir une game life national d'écouté
des nouvelles on avait pris l'habitude
d'aller là cela dit pour tes d'accord
écoutez écoutez françois legault
d'angoulême bien être notre premier
ministre on est bien content que l'on
tire comme telle à dire commence aussi à
monsieur laquelle jean d'affluence que
le genre d'achalandage vous aviez dans
vos restaurants là lors des dernières
semaines le mois de juin par exemple ça
ressemble à quoi
on avait quand même eu un très très bon
départ en plus surprenant mais mieux
fait beau la décision d'ouvrir de façon
graduelle plus le soir je dirais qu'on
pouvait le penser à 65 soit les 10 %
d'occupation qui de volume d'attaqués
quand même bon le contenu de la façon
qu'on nous opéré c'est un courage un
mail à l'automne les terrasses vont
fermer le brut est à voir partir on sait
pour ce qui est un peu incertain
on est tous content un look lesparre
reviennent mais risque de compenser pas
mal le seul cette baisse de capacités de
combat voire aviv au cours des
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
avec les stations durable confirme à
quel genre de baisse de revenus vous
avez subi au panel confinement de
pratiquement perdu l'ensemble de nos
revenus nous pour 195 pour sanofi sur
les salles à manger fait donc on nous a
fermé les salles à manger pour moins me
en faisant un petit peu de livraisons
quand on a commencé sur je pense que ces
initiatives furent respect que nous
aider à garder un minimum nos jeunes à
l'emploi elle certains cuisiniers
directeur mail avec l'ouverture des
salles à manger basterds retour qui est
plus graduelle que veut dire le tour
suivant bontemps deuxième phase quand
même intéressante pour nous donner sa
conscience
aucun bus quand même pas mal de mises à
pied temporaires savez que vous êtes
entré de rappeler les jeunes oui on n'a
plus le choix était orné théâtre les
régions où l'on a tout arrêté
as tu un retour avec dd à des
contraintes plus difficile moins de
places assises des heures d'ouverture
réduites avec du matériel on a beaucoup
de gens aussi qui dans la restauration
en ce moment sur poser question pas
facile pour personne très bien dans une
cuisine avec un masque ni lunettes à 42
guérit tout dans un contexte très très
difficile en ce moment pour la
restauration
on vous souhaite bonne chance et surtout
on se souhaite monsieur bédard que le
canadien
à une loi en série merci pour tout le
monde effectivement jean bédard merci
beaucoup merci